Let's go ahead and continue our conversation
talking about basic lighting and shadow concepts.
Let's go ahead and dive right in.
So one of the things I'm gonna continually point out
to you is some of the Lumen settings
you have to keep in mind when working
with the post-process volume.
You'll see that there is a Lumen scene lighting quality
as well as a Lumen scene detail.
Now Lumen scene lighting quality,
this is gonna allow us to be able to calculate
with higher fidelity our visuals and our scene.
Now keep in mind as you go higher
this can be GPU expensive.
And you'll see me point that out many times
in the breakdowns in the slide deck.
So you'll also see a Lumen scene detail.
This controls the size of instances
that can be calculated in a scene.
So you'll see if you have larger settings
it'll help smaller objects,
but it again, it is GPU expensive.
There's also a Lumen scene distance.
This sets a maximum view distance
of the scene that Lumen maintains for ray tracing against.
Now, this is nice to be able to dial this down.
If your scene is small
you may not want everything calculated all at one time
or at least pared down to particular region.
Again, you can do that via your post-process volume too
as an encapsulated for a particular region
or like we did in the beginning
make it have an infinite build so that it's controlling
or influencing the whole environment.
But this gives you a secondary dial down for that.
The final gather quality is important
because as you scale this up
this can reduce noise in your scene.
And you'll also see their screen traces.
I like to use a C-bar which we go over
in our intro to lighting class
which can prevent screen traces or strange reflections
and refractions from popping up
when you move your camera around.
Now, this tries to help that a little bit
but again, there is a C-bar we go over in that class
that can actually support that a little bit better.
There's max trace distance
as well as scene capture, catch resolution.
Now, all these you can crank up if you want to
but I recommend it goes slow and then go high.
You'll see the max trace distance here
because not everything is by default right here at 20,000.
Not everything needs to go higher.
Like this can stay steady
and you can also lower some things.
So you'll see Lumen scene lighting quality.
We can keep that at a 1.5.
We don't necessarily have to go higher.
You have to try it out and test it as you go.
Again, you don't want to crank everything out
up to the maximum all at one time.
You want to go low, then go high.
You'll also notice that you can influence
a bit of your visuals
with the ability to be able to control your roughness
with a roughness dial down
that you get within your shader.
But there's also a roughness control
inside of the post-process volume for a sweeping control.
This can help with any noise that may be persistent.
You'll notice with a high reflective surface
noise gets pretty loud there and it shows up pretty strong
or you can dial up the roughness
and eliminate some of the noise that may occur.
So you'll see Lumen reflections here.
Also kind of the same thing.
You want to start low, then go high.
And you'll see that we have a method that we can choose too.
So you can actually use and pair things up
where you have a Lumen reflectivity
but then you have maybe screen space GI
and that can also be used in games.
You can pair things together if you need to.
Now, this is the CVAR I told you guys about
where you can do screen traces
and you can use Lumen reflection screen traces.
And this actually works a bit better
than working with the screen traces
that we were talking about earlier.
High quality translucency reflections
activating high quality mirror reflections
on the front layer on a translucent surface.
But again, when it is higher, it is at a higher cost.
So you have to keep all these things in mind
when you're working with stuff.
And here's the max roughness trace I told you about.
So be careful with that
but that allows you to do a sweeping control.
If your surfaces you're noticing need that.
Let's go and jump into Unreal.
And what we're gonna do is start building a few things out
and later on in other lectures
we'll talk about mega lights.
So right now we're in the interior of the kit bash scene
that I created for you guys to play with.
It's in the same scene that we had before our project
which is our UF.
This is a scene we used for Unreal Fest
world building concepts and lighting.
Let's go and jump in there and take a look
and see what we can do to make things
even look better with the lighting.
Now it's pretty dark here.
We can see your character.
She's kind of sitting in the floor here.
Let's push her up a little bit.
There you go.
That's a little more ergonomically correct.
So what we're gonna do now
is mess with the lighting here and exposure.
We see that we have our post-process volume.
Now we can decide whether we want this to again
control the whole environment
or make it so it's infinite extended bound.
In this case, we have infinite extended bound.
Let's go back to our method of global illumination.
Let's pop this up and turn these on.
So we have ray lighting mode.
We're using the project settings.
And again, this can be used as an override
and we're gonna mess with the lumen lighting quality.
We'll bump this up just a little bit
to remove some of the noise that may occur
as well as the detail.
And final gather is also gonna help fix some of the noise.
Now we're not gonna go all the way up to two
but we're gonna get kind of close
because there is a little bit of noise
that occurs in the materials.
But again, we can control that via reflectivity
with the noise slider
or we can do that via the material itself.
There's a screen distance.
I'll turn that on, but we're not necessarily gonna use it
and we don't necessarily need screen traces at this time.
And again, that may help if you run into some problems
with some refraction highlighted areas
that seem to disappear and reappear in your scene.
And we have the scene capture, catch resolution scale.
And again, scale factor for lumen surface,
catch resolution for scene capture.
Smaller values have GPU, save GPU memory
at a cost and quality.
The default is 0.5.
We're gonna keep ours at one, which is fine.
It says the default is 0.5,
but you'll notice it doesn't have a return to sender
or go back to its original state here.
So it looks like the default is one.
So that's just a little bit of a pro tip
we may need to edit later.
And we're gonna go in here and go to lumen reflections.
And we have a lot of reflective surfaces in here.
So I'm gonna not mess with the screen traces here.
Again, this can be a problem.
If you move your camera
and you'll notice a hotspot disappears,
clipping at the end.
And again, that CVAR I shared with you
is a better CVAR to work with than the actual tick box.
And let's go high quality translucency.
Sure, we'll do that.
We do have some mirrored surfaces
such as the windows here on the side.
And let's go back to that post-process volume.
And we'll have a max refraction bounces
and we'll set that to like maybe like a five.
There we go.
There comes a point where your eye
is not going to pick it up.
You can set it at like five or seven.
They just won't be able to pick it up.
We give you the luxury and the option
to be able to increase that,
but you're really not gonna get that.
And your human eye is not gonna really pick up
the finite details from a certain point.
That's kind of like you've reached the limit.
All right, so let's put some lights in here.
And what we're gonna start off with
is gonna use a Rec Light.
This is one of my favorite lights to use.
This is one I used a whole bunch
for Love, Death and Robots
when Unreal was partnering with Blur Studios.
And I'm gonna go ahead and rotate this 90 degrees.
There we go.
And we're gonna make it so it's movable
because you wanna make sure your lights are movable
when you're using Lumen
because that makes it so that updates on the fly
and works best with our virtual shadow maps.
Now, a lot of people's tendency
when we're working with lights,
we'll say, hey, I'm gonna put a light here
and I'm gonna put on each one.
Now, believe it or not,
that can get expensive after a while.
So one of the better ways to handle that
is to go in here and make it so that the light,
especially if they're close together,
you can use a single light such as this Rec Light
and you can stretch it along that length
of how these are set.
So I'm gonna go in here and set my width here
a little bit and we're gonna move it over.
And we want it to encompass all these lights
and we'll make the width a little bit bigger.
There we go.
And we can make it even a little bit bigger than that
so it covers all of them just enough
and move that over right there.
Awesome.
Now look at that.
No one is the wiser with that.
That's a set of lights that we set in
using that Rec Light.
We can choose from here to do the barn door
if we want to.
Now the barn door angle and the length
as well as mainly our source width and source height
are gonna determine whether it's a hard shadow
or a soft shadow.
What that means is as I scale this light up here
in the details, not in the scene,
it's easy to get lost with that
and think it's like 3D Studio Max or Maya
but in the details, if I mess with this,
the light will actually lose energy.
See it gets softer as I increase that size.
So that's one way to understand
how to keep those shadows stronger
or have them softer is messing with the actual scale
or I should say height in this case
and width to be able to control that.
There we go.
We can soften it up if you want to.
I'm gonna keep it right about here.
I think that works pretty well.
And then from here, we can add a few more lights
whether they're coming in from the outdoors or not.
And we can also mess with a little bit of our exposure.
If we want it to be a little bit more moody
we can darken it just a bit there if we wanted to.
And from here we can add in some external lights
for our computers so I can add in another Rec Light.
And again, point to note Rec Lights and Point Lights
are two of the most expensive lights to work with.
The Rec Light is like a series of point lights
set into a square initially
and can be shaped into whatever you want
such as a rectangle.
So you have to keep those things in mind
when you're using it.
Let's go and rotate this.
Now remember glowing items can give us light
but if we wanted to highlight that
just a little bit more, we can do so.
So let's go ahead and remember
don't mess with the widgets for scale
in here in the scene, but in the details only.
We'll make that a little bit here
and we will scale that down just a little bit.
Here we go, I think that's fine.
And we'll move this in, we'll move it down.
We'll move it across.
And we do want to lower its strength
because it is blown out pretty hard here.
And we'll lower this to like a two
and we'll give it a nice yellowish color.
And again, we can use the dropper if we wanted to.
A more of a dramatic effect here.
There you go, and that looks much better.
And if with the G key
you can see a little more dramatic effect
looking at the monitors, getting the information
that the person needs, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
And then we can also use another light here
such as a point light.
And again, make sure, let me hit the G key here
so you can see them.
Make sure that these items are movable.
I'll go back and fix the one we have on our monitor here.
I'm gonna move this over.
I'm gonna dumb this guy down pretty heavily
because we don't want it too strong.
I could use a Rec Light
but because this is a unique shape,
I'm gonna keep it here.
I can leave the shadow on if I want to
or turn it off if I just want a kind of a glow going on.
I can set this to like a simple, like one.
And make that a yellow color.
So again, we can use the dropper.
I'll say, hey, we're gonna grab that color there.
There you go.
And if we want it to make it a little richer, we can.
Say, hey, you want this to be a little more orange-ish.
We can grab the light we have here
make that movable too.
And then we can move this over here.
Now, one thing I wanna mention when building your worlds
there is, as I move this light over here
I'll keep this conversation going.
There is a factor that you can run into
when you're kind of like,
hey, I'm working on a mobile device.
I'm working on a kind of a low poly game.
And in that game, you have a lot of items
that are like maybe welded together.
That can be an issue with Unreal when you're using Lumen.
So one thing you do wanna keep in mind
let's move this over here a little bit better.
One thing you wanna keep in mind when doing that
is you wanna make sure, there you go, nice and isolated.
You wanna make sure that you're getting the correct shadows
and a way to edit that or keep that in mind
let me hit the G key so we can see our lighting.
Pretty good, getting in the right direction there.
One thing you wanna do is if you have a welded object
the problem you can run into with Unreal Lumen
out of the box is you can actually get some black shadows
in your reflections of that welded object.
So in that case, when that occurs
you wanna go to that object.
I'm gonna pick on the ceiling here.
We're gonna double click on this cube.
I'm gonna pull up the mesh editor window.
You wanna go in here and you wanna adjust
the mesh cards.
Let's start mesh, there you go.
And then put cards.
These are already present, there he is.
And you may have to increase these.
So that'll make it so those black areas
will occur a less.
Again, Unreal's Lumen likes it
so you build things modularly.
And you can see that in here
I've built a lot of things modularly in here
and I've even grouped or I've went in here
and I parented the items that I needed
to be able to come together.
I can see this particular one is grouped.
And this one over here too is in a blueprint.
And you wanna make sure when that happens
that you do have things welded together.
If you run into that issue
and what I mean by welded is like seamless
like old school where you say, hey, I'm gonna make a wall.
I weld another wall together
and I weld the floor together.
That's very old school.
So when you are doing that,
that doesn't mean you can't use it with Lumen.
You just have to increase those mesh cards
because if it appears in reflective surfaces
it could be black because what Lumen likes
is individual modulated pieces built like the real world.
And it actually can be pretty helpful
when you're building your world for games
to be able to have that modulated pieces
that you can bring together and put together
and build things on like in sets.
Because when you do that,
you might be able to mix and match a little bit easier
than committing for a welding of your items.
So just keep those things in mind
when building those shadow issues may occur.
Well, that's it.
With this one in the next video
we'll dive a bit deeper into lighting
and we'll talk a bit about mega lights.